[Music]
okay hello and welcome to trigonometry
I'm Frances foster I'm Constance and
kissin and this is a show for you if
you're bored of people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about at trigonometry we don't pretend
to be the experts we ask the experts
our fantastic expert guests this week is
an LBC radio presenter
iandale welcome to chicken alone hi
[Music]
thank you thank you so much for coming
on I was about to introduce you as a
conservative and then you said no no no
let's have a conversation about it so
why didn't you first time I'll tell us a
little bit about how you got to where
you are and then we'll get into the
whole conservative not conservative
thing um well God how do I start why did
I start off I studied German believe it
or not at the university staying here
and was intended to be a German teacher
languages for my things anything I was
good at at school can I just interrupt
you there's a former teacher in well
done Joe there's probably like wonders
whether at some point I mean I was 56
yesterday so there is still time but
I've always thought I might go back
there to do it
don't I'm not they say even being a
secondary school I couldn't cope with
that anyway I go into politics at
university and ended up working the
House of Commons for a couple of years
for a Tory MP back in the mid 80s
when politics really was great fun and
then I had a succession of jobs in
lobbying I was a financial journalist I
opened a political bookshop in
Westminster became a publisher and then
got into broadcasting and that's why I
got into our BC so that's the sort of
potted history and I've always been
politically interested I always remember
my grandmother said to me in about 1974
never trust the labour party because
they always spend more than they can
afford and Michel foots a communist
right on the first one and I actually
started off as a liberal and I would
still say I still am a liberal him
we did a project after we've done our
own levels in 1978 at the end of the
term it was on local politics we had to
meet the local liberal mayor of saffron
walden that's where I grew up in Essex
and I was really impressed by her so I
joined the Liberal Party for six months
the nice sort of speech by Margaret
Thatcher which I see must have been at
the 1978 Tory Party conference I thought
well I agree with every word she said so
I then switched to becoming a Tory and I
stood for Parliament in 2005 in North
Norfolk with the electorate fought back
I always wanted to be either an MP or
radio was it a close race that one no
it's a rather did I what I did was um I
applied to be the candidate in North
Norfolk which you think of Norfolk is
quite conservative area and it is and it
had always been a conservative seat
until 2001 when the Liberal Democrats
normal and wanted by I think four
hundred and eighty three votes so I
thought well I can win that back but it
soon became apparent that I mean he was
very very properly hid for the seat
three times but always very well knowing
good constituency MP so it was quite
difficult to differentiate myself from
him he had a little bit Euroskeptic for
a Liberal Democrat and to all intents
and purposes was a sort of fairly
moderate conservative voice I always
remember one day in February 2005
canvassing in a one of the coastal
villages called over strand lots of big
houses beautiful natural Tory voters
every single one of them that we knocked
on the door said something along the
lines of well we really like you but
Norman's such a nice man going home that
evening saying to my parlor this is just
not going to happen I think I think I
probably knew that way before that but
that really brought it home and on the
night I lost by ten thousand six hundred
votes so that was a bit of a blow I did
try again in the next part of it but I
took two years out to start a new
business and I don't you can't really
apply for seats finally to in that and I
left it too late I nearly got Bracknell
but yeah we just wasn't to be so after
2010 I thought no that's it and when I
got the job at LBC I didn't renew my
Tory Party membership so that's why I
didn't want to be introduced as a
conservative because in many ways I'm
not anymore
I voted Liberal Democrat in the last
local elections in time which was partly
because and you'll know because you live
though it's a very corrupt local council
they want to spend ninety million pounds
on a new Civic Centre and trying to
pretend to the electorate it's not going
to cost them any money well of course it
is in on social issues I'm much more
left-wing than I used to be partly
because of my radio show because I hear
people's experiences if you have people
telling you
day after day how awful the bedroom tax
is and what the effects on them or
universal credit it does shift your
preconceptions a bit and so I can see
the logic of the bedroom tax but the way
it's been implemented just hasn't worked
so I'm still from an economic point of
view very sort of dry and right-wing I
guess I'm voted leave so complete brexit
here but on a lot of issues I'm not your
stereotypical conservative vote anymore
it's such a fascinating point you make
about being having your mind changed by
listening to me more talking this is
what we try and do on the show and we
find that it's happening less and less
people actually having genuine
conversation and being able to change
each other's minds so that's such a
great point was there a particular
moment when you thought well this is the
one story that kind of changed my mind
on this or some other issue well I've
been doing radio now and on a daily
basis since 2010 so I don't know how
many people I've talked to and all the
shows that I don't want to calculate it
one day I suppose but it will be tens of
thousands and they've all got stories to
tell some of them very emotional stories
and I do I remember one particular
failure it wasn't that long ago actually
on universal credit which you think I'll
blow the phone on use of the universal
credit how can that be interesting and I
do I can't say I ever relish doing
benefits phonies because they can be
slightly you I ever get people phoning
in saying what's all these fun jersey
and taking out tax payers money and all
the rest of it
or you get the opposite now on this
phone in I had three male callers
towards the end of the hour who phoned
in and they all were crying and you
think well they're not acting
something's happened in their life in
their their dealings with the developer
working pensions that has driven them to
the brink of despair and and there are
subjects that people people phone in and
they're incredibly emotional and it's I
mean I can be a very emotional person I
mean I'll cry Emmerdale say it's it
doesn't take much to set me off and I
talked about I mean when my mother died
I would talked about that quite a lot
and broke down once and I've got no one
since I've got no embarrassment about
sort of showing emotion but in some ways
you do because you're suppose you've got
a professional role to transact so you
don't want to be known as sort of that
the crybaby presenter all the time but
that was what I can't mean what it was I
was one time I know what it was it was
Lee Rigby you know he was murdered in
college I was on air when that just
after that happened and a couple of days
afterwards I think it was I suddenly got
flashed on my screen the statement from
the Ministry of Defence issued on behalf
of his as either his girlfriend or his
mother I can't remember so I started
reading this out and now normally I
would read I would read it to myself
before I read it out which kind of kills
the emotion a little bit but I read it
and I got to the bit which talked about
his children
and I just completely lost it and I went
sigh I mean I everyone listening could
tell what my voice was choking and I
literally went sign up for two seconds
while I sort of gathered myself and that
was about seven minutes before the end
of the hour and then just before the end
of the hour I apologize for that because
it was very unprofessional I'm sorry it
happened and the text and Twitter feed
just went mad saying why have you
apologized we were doing the same so you
can feel it myself do you now they said
any normal person would have done that
why do you think that is real
every Center you shouldn't show us that
you're emotional when we're being
emotional and that was quite comforting
because I could have got I mean you're
not on the radio to emote you're there
to do a job and to read what's in front
of you if you've got something to read I
had an incident the other day where we
was talking about gay conversion therapy
and at a guy right at the end of the
hour he said he lived on council estate
in Yorkshire
he was probably his twenties found it
quite difficult to articulate what his
views were initially but once he got
going he was fine and this was leading
up to the end of the program and I
stopped on 59 minutes policy out and
then Nigel Farage comes on to do his
talk up at 58 15 he told me that he was
thinking of killing himself that night
well well put yourself in that situation
they were what as a radio presenter do
you say to him at that point because you
know that one word out of place and it
could be seen as encouraging him to do
it obviously wouldn't mean it to be and
also obviously off comment Amin and you
potentially lose your job and all I
could think of was saying well Ryan stay
on the line I'll talk to you after the
show
I've just got to finish the show and
I'll come into the gallery and talk to
you which I did and it was fine and we
ended up having a joke about he was so
no he didn't watch the World Cup match
tonight so I said yes I am he said yeah
I'm watching that all those men in there
tied show so you sort of think well has
that done the trick has that sort of I
don't think he genuinely really meant
that he was going to do it but I did
have another instance years ago built on
the m25 always I will always remember
where he was apps he convinced me that
he genuinely was thinking about doing it
and I kept him on for 20 minutes and I
mean I'm not a trained I mean I did do
it I was one of the counselors on
Nightline at my university but I'm not
trained to talk people off off the edge
so all you can do is talk and I kept
thinking to myself how do I get him how
do I stop this conversation I can't
remember how I stopped it anyway I asked
him to speak to my producer
when I finished then he found in the
next night and told us that he had tried
to kill himself I think he was with
pills and then but then he thought or I
and Laura my producer had said to him
and then he called 999
I knew obviously survived that sue shows
how radios such an intimate medium and
you do have this one-to-one relationship
with people
and that's why I love radio I don't
particularly like doing TV which you'll
think is ridiculous thing at the amount
that I've been doing over the last six
months by don't enjoy TV in the same way
that I draw a radio because you don't
have that connection with the audience
that radio gives you a lot of the time
with radio what is amazing with it is
like you said the connection is amazing
how people tweet in lovely to hear your
voice again and you know and then a to
have a chat with you on Twitter and
sometimes you get the the opposite like
I'm very programming and I got called by
one of the Twitter's who follows talks
well I got called a [ __ ]
terrorist sympathizer because I said
yeah because I said I didn't think
bricks it would be a particularly good
idea well as we both know that happens
on both sides
yeah I I've been involved yesterday was
my birthday and I spent virtually the
entire day on Twitter
arguing brexit with people why am i
doing yeah we must win
well there is poor to me that would love
to just say to you know I'm not going to
talk about percocet anymore because I
mean if I'm bored with it god knows what
other muscle other people must feel like
but going back to this unique
relationship it it's
I mean Ivan I sometimes if I get abuse I
mean people send in texts and what they
don't know is that I see their phone
number at the bottom of the time yeah
so sometimes if I get horrible ones I
text them back saying by the way just so
you know I've reported you to the
Metropolitan Police of course I haven't
yeah but I don't know yeah yeah and they
usually oh I'm really sorry I didn't
mean it I was just spur-of-the-moment
thing you know I really like you I think
you're a top presenter and it is
astonishing the things that people will
say to you via social media or text
whereas if they were sitting next to you
they just wouldn't dream of it it's
incredible and the terrible you've
tweeted me I'm sorry but it is it is
incredible what people will say like
with doing the show the kind of stuff
that people will put online about us or
I guess just like for no reason
whatsoever well you wait till you see
what comes after this yeah well I'm
looking forward to coming back to
politics today I was interested that you
said that you worked for a Tory MP in
the 80s when politics was fun yeah I'm
still fun what does that mean what do
you mean about politics being fun by I
think it may be just because of my age
what in your twenties you see things
through a very different prison than you
do when you're in your 50s and it's like
the World Cup when we lost the World Cup
semi-final last week oh yeah I was
disappointed but I didn't feel at all
emotional about it but in 1990 when I
was 27 losing to Germany I was with I
was in a hole with 800 insurance brokers
watching this and 800 grown men in
floods of tears that it didn't affect me
like that this time and politics
maybe it's because I'm looking at it now
from the point of view of an outsider
rather than an insider and when Margaret
Thatcher was Prime Minister you kind of
felt things mattered there were big
issues in the 1980s that really mattered
the Cold War which people now completely
forget and the economy in the in the
late 1970s when I became first
politically interested I mean it was
just a basket case and people don't 27%
inflation I mean people don't remember
that anymore so that that was what drove
me to get involved in politics
felt part of it whereas now I'm not part
of it apart from interviewing
politicians all the time
and I think I look at it in a very
different way slightly more detached and
people keep saying to me wall do you not
want to stand for Parliament again no I
don't I've only got asked to stand as
Tory for mayor of London the other day
pew because I've got quite a bit name
recognition in London and I said I would
rather stick hot nails down my knob why
is that because I've kind of been there
done that
I still think politics matters but if if
a good friend of me said should I go
into politics nowadays I would advise
him not to which is a terrible thing
when I told my mum that I wasn't going
to stand for Parliament again she
cheered I was thinking well she ought to
be really sad about that because you
ought to be proud that your son is gonna
wants to do sort of public service but
she took the view that if I remember in
2010 she said well you could have got
got caught up in that expensive scandal
and the truth is of course I could have
done because many people did not through
no fault of their own it was the system
some people did through their own fault
has to be said and she didn't like all
of the public scrutiny she knew because
I was gay that I would have had much
much more scrutiny than maybe others so
I am sad that I've never been an MP
because I think I would have liked it I
think I'd be good at it but it wasn't to
be in looking back at the 80s and
especially with such as government I
mean there were some things that they
brought in which were homophobic if you
think about the the common member what
the section was called now the one yeah
section 28 in schools was there not part
of you as a gay man that solder and
thought hang on that is I don't agree
with that in the slightest well at the
time this was in 1988 and I'm probably
going to give you too much information
here I was I was 26 and I knew I was gay
but I'd never actually done anything
about it
and I remember logical izing this to
myself if I said word on the basis that
it was designed to prevent the promotion
of homosexuality whereas the narrative
now is that it was designed to prevent
any discussion whatsoever now I think
that probably was the effect of it
because teachers were sort of nervous
about well if I talk about it does that
count as promotion now I don't believe
it's the role of teachers to promote
anything to their class and to their
children so that was how I sort of
rationalized it at the time I'm looking
back yeah I would not have been knowing
what I know now I would not have
supported it and I think that has
clouded every single discussion about
the Conservative Party and homosexuality
ever since and even now virtually every
month in one of the gay magazines
there's always an article about the
wicked Tories in section 28 forgetting
all of the progress that the Tory party
has made on that issue which I played a
very very small part in that I remember
when I was selected as a candidate I was
the first openly gay candidate to have
been selected having told the selection
committee in terms that I was gay now I
was slightly forced to do that because
I'd forgotten that I'd agreed to speak
at some gay fringe meeting the Tory
Party conference and I remember the
Association Chairman bringing me up
singing and we've got a little bit of an
issue in that people have seen that
you're speaking at this event and he
knew I was gay anyway and I said why is
that an issue well it's just that people
sort of aren't very happy and I said
okay well I'll address it in the next
because that was by that says I got to
through to the second round of the
selection so I done my speech done my
questions and answers and at the end I
actually primed somebody in the audience
to ask me the question and they they
worded it rather beautifully they said
is this an issue that means a lot to you
so what didn't because they weren't
allowed to ask if I was gay
so I prepared a statement and it was
quite a sort of tearjerker in a way
and it was sort of swell many of you
sitting in the audience you will know
people who are gay you may not know that
you know people that gave it could be a
dustman it could be a hairdresser it
could be whoever but does that affect
the way they do their job
it doesn't me being gay affect the way
that I would do my job and I mean I got
standing ovations at the end of it and
they selected me with a 66% majority now
bear in mind this was North Norfolk not
the most liberal area in the country to
say something so I thought well good on
them and they haven't let it affect them
they've judged me on what they think my
abilities are and they selected me now
the electorate didn't take that for you
and some people have said well do you
think that the majority was so big
because I mean some of my opponents
obviously sort of promoted that I was
gay because they knew it wouldn't go
down well I think there will have been
some people that didn't vote for me
because of that but I don't think it was
I think they it was mainly because they
knew that normally I was a really good
MP that but so I've never blamed my
defeat on on that and then sort of
subsequent to that you've had the
Conservatives introduce equal marriage
and I don't think although quite a lot
of conservative MPs oppose that I don't
think there would be many conservative
MPs now if it came back if somebody put
down a motion to repeal equal marriage
I'd like to think there will be no
Conservative MPs that voted for that but
I'd be surprised if if there were I'd be
surprised if it was more than five now I
think people need to accept that the
Conservative Party has come a long way
on these issues in some cases sort of
been dragged in screaming but we are
where we are and I think it's about time
that people acknowledged that and what
would you say to those people who say
that the Conservative Party is in
inverted commas they're nasty party the
party of austerity the party who
demonized as a poor the party brought in
the bedroom test which let's be fair has
caught a huge amount of suffering to
working for I don't think that there are
any politicians on which in whichever
party that deliberately bring in
policies designed because they think
they will harm people that's not how it
works
you really would have to be a pretty
nasty individual to bring in a I mean
taking in Duncan Smith and Universal
Credit and welfare reform I remember
back when he was leading the
Conservative Party and he went to this
council estate in Glasgow Easter house
and he was profoundly moved by what he
saw there I thought well this has been a
Labour Council for 60 years and they've
left these people in this state they've
had the chance to improve their lives
and they've done nothing so I mean he
could argue that the Labour Party was a
nasty party fit for doing that
and I remember he came to visit me when
I was a candidate we went round a drugs
rehabilitation centre and I listened to
the conversations he had with drug
addicts and I was one of them there that
knew his cousin and I mean it was quite
a emotional conversation now that man is
not motivated by hate or spy he
genuinely wanted to reform the system to
help the kind of people that he'd seen
in the in this counsellor stage and I've
seen them in my political life these are
states that that whichever political
parties have just left to rot because
they know that the people generally
don't vote very much so they feel that
although the political strategists feel
they can be ignored now so I think he
was motivated by the best of intentions
how do you though do meaningful reform
of the welfare system which is so
incredibly complex it eats up so much
public money I think it's a really
difficult challenge so when you I think
all part all parties have agree that
Universal Credit is a good idea trying
to bring all those benefits into one but
clearly there have been terrible issues
in how it's being implemented now who do
you blame for that do you blame the
politicians do you blame the civil
servants who effectively I mean the
politicians will say to the civil
servants right this is what we want to
do tell us how we do it now in the end
the buck does stop with the Secretary of
State there has to be somebody who's
formally accountable to it but he hasn't
he wasn't served well by his civil
servants and it goes to be a lot of
people since how dare
I'll blame the civil servants well sorry
simple servants do get away with an
awful lot in this country and I'm not
held accountable for it we do have some
very fine civil servants but we also
have some very very incompetent ones and
it's about time that we recognize that
and when there are systemic failures in
what happens they need to be called out
and yes blame the politicians all you
like but in the end there are many more
people to blame as well well if you ever
do run for Parliament again but coming
back to France is in question I mean I'm
an outsider in this country I'm an
immigrant I came here when I was about
12 I keep reminding you about my well I
keep reminding myself it's just fact
but it's it's like a given to me that de
Torre brand is a toxic brand and yeah
we've had a conservative-led government
for years how does that happen in a
country which supposedly hates the
Tories yeah we have an Atari government
well we have a shy Tory phenomena and
only people who don't tell the opinion
pollsters that they vote Tory that I
think there is still people feel I don't
know but they feel shame or
embarrassment about voting Tory I don't
think anybody should be ashamed of who
they vote for it's like you Kipp were
never identified in the opinion polls
until 2014 really because the opinion
polling companies never picked them up I
think it's the same with Donald Trump in
America that there are a lot of people
that just didn't tell the polling
companies that they were going to vote
for him so he a lot of people felt that
he was going to win but all of the
so-called experts didn't see it coming
and then what their howls of sort of
disbelief afterwards and still are I
think people always contrast political
parties and they compare whether they
think they are actually capable of
governing when Tony Blair was leader of
the Labour Party people felt that I mean
I he I never voted for him but he didn't
scare me he didn't sort of frighten the
electoral horses in the way that maybe
Neil Kinnock did or maybe now Jeremy
Corbyn does and with some people
and there is there is a phenomenon sort
of stick this stick to nurse for fear of
something worse and that's Theresa May
is biggest asset at the moment where I
mean when this goes out you may not even
be promised Sheena survives so often
because there is no alternative really
and there's nobody waiting to take about
the plenty waiting to take over but
there's no ready-made alternative and
people look at poor Ben if you I mean
why is labour not 20 points ahead in the
opinion polls when you've got probably
the most incompetent Tory government
what's in since the last one I mean they
should be 20 points ahead and under Tony
Blair they were well I mean John Major I
think you can compare to Teresa may in
some ways or his government because
there was complete chaos in the 1990s
again over Europe but labor just cannot
seem to break through in the way now
they keep say our but we did so well in
the last election campaign we went up by
10 points or whatever he didn't win
though even though you keep trying to
pretend you did way that you are not in
government get used to that and they can
tell well it'll happen again in the next
election we put in another temp why it
doesn't work like that
and I I do wonder now whether we've
reached peak Corbin where the novelty
has worn off when do you have a see
Jeremy call been doing anything nowadays
he doesn't really do any interviews
before he was elected Labour leader I
would interview him every two or three
weeks on my show and he was always if we
couldn't find another Labour MP Jeremy
Corbyn was always a backstop he would
recycle down from Islington and come
into the studio and I got like a house
on fire with him we was he knew exactly
where I came from we had some really
good discussions since he's been Labour
leader not a single interview and that's
because Seamus mill his director
communications clearly thinks that we're
all fascists and therefore must be
avoided at all costs but I think that's
a real problem for them because if you
are as lead the opposition you need to
be out there fighting the good fight now
you can talk to your momentum rallies
till the cows come home but you're not
persuading anybody need to vote for you
by doing that you are just confirming
the view that you're a bit of a lefty
the sense centre ground people can't
trust to be in government
oh you mentioned about his about the
people behind him who run his campaign
do you think part of the reason why they
don't put him in front of people like
you
is it Corbin does have some pretty dodgy
values for instance he's refusing to
criticize the government Venezuela now
my fat my mother's from Venezuela and I
know firsthand the terrible atrocities
that are happening there and I used to
vote labor and the fact that he refuses
to condemn them I I would merely undoes
refused to condemn them I mean here
McDonnell actually have praised Maduro
yes now I don't understand all of that
I really don't but I don't think that's
the reason why they won't do interviews
I just think that they think they can
bypass the mainstream media now and use
Facebook and social media to get to the
people that they think they need well I
think they grow on that because you've
got to have a sort of multi-faceted
approach bear in mind that old people
are the ones that actually turn out to
vote and all that was the fantasy that
at the last election it was the 18 to 24
year olds that pushed the Labour vote up
they did vote in slightly larger numbers
than before it wasn't actually it was a
25 to 45 age group but if they can tap
in to older people and they've got a
tremendous opportunity to do this now
and that's how they could win but they
show no sign of looking at doing that
whatsoever
and just going back to Venezuela because
I find it absolutely baffling when I
talk to labour voters I go but you do
understand that he's in support Medora
and then I yeah but it doesn't really
matter does it and it's you know it's a
long I got told by one person yeah but
it's it's very far away isn't it the
country of which we know nothing yeah so
I mean why do you think that in why do
you think that it's so it's
reprehensible for him to come out and
support with Maduro well I mean that
they kept praising Chavez and saying
well this is what socialism can do they
were actually using the Venezuelan
economy as a model for what they would
want to do
and now that the Venezuelan economy I
mean it's probably the most basket-case
economy in the whole world at the moment
they now of course blame the Americans
for that yeah now I can't quite see how
that works but that's what they do
they've always got an answer and they
will never ever admit that they're wrong
on Venezuela but the electorate in many
ways discount that at you're right
just as they discount the fact that he
used to meet with the IRA just the fact
that they discount the fact that he met
with Hamas he's cultivated this image as
a sort of gentle old uncle figure and he
has become a bit of a cult as L in that
this is a fascinating thing to watch he
I think his strings are pulled entirely
by Seamus Miller John McDonald I don't
think he's got an original thought in
his head now he believes exactly the
same as he believed in 1985 now that's a
good thing in some ways they'd be like
consistency in politicians but he hasn't
adapted to the modern world and he can
never bring himself to say anything
positive about America about Israel but
he will always find positive things to
say about Russia about sort of certain
countries in the Middle East that you
know I might find reprehensible he used
to take money from Press TV but mentally
I did a few programs on that as well but
I think I was paid 75 pounds for doing
three programs News paid 20 grand he's
never said well in retrospect I was
wrong to do that
and I really deprecated the Iranian
regime's views on homosexuality and all
the rest of it it's never done that and
I find it very strange that he cannot er
supportive words to that kind of regime
and treat Israel with the contempt that
he does now Israel gets a lot of things
wrong I'll be the first to admit that
but it is a democracy it is a fairly
liberal democracy in terms of social
issues but you'll never find him
acknowledging that do you think he's
unelectable no I don't I think the
Conservatives are doing their best to
make him electable and because of what's
happening on break sir
I think there are a lot of conservatives
who will well I know there are because
they tell me all the time on my program
but they either won't vote conservative
or they won't vote at all and I mean my
partner's a good example is someone
who's not really that interested in
politics but sort of listens to the
Jeremy Vine show on Radio 2 and that's
where he gets most of its current
affairs knowledge from so it's been the
other day is it true that brexit might
not happen and I said well I don't I
think it will happen but there are lots
of people are trying to make it not
happen including lots within the
conservative Authority and so what if it
doesn't happen I will never vote Tory
again it's not only that I will never
vote again and I've had so many people
say this in particularly people who
maybe voted for the first time in the
referendum because it's somehow on
either side is somehow enthused them and
I get a lot of calls texts tweets from
people saying well if we're if we're
betrayed on this I should never take
part of the democratic process again and
that is extremely worrying because it
leaves a gap for someone like Steve
Bannon who we were talking about earlier
who said on LBC yesterday that Tommy
Robinson was a great British hero and
that there will soon be a revolution in
Britain now Paul Masson who I normally
don't agree with on anything he tweeted
that he thinks that when Tommy Robinson
comes out of prison he will get huge
American funding to start up a sort of
Tea Party type organization to try and
rip down the UK political establishment
and I thought Jesus I agree with Paul
Masson he's absolutely right on that and
what a frightening prospect that will be
because whatever you think of Tommy
Robertson I actually try and ignore him
I don't have him on my show but whatever
you think of him and his views he is an
incredibly articulate human being and to
many people will be quite plausible and
when you are in a time of political
turmoil
it only takes one demagogue to really
pull the whole sack of court house of
cards down now whether he would be
capable of doing that I don't know
Oh Nigel Farage is now saying that he's
going to get back into politics because
he thinks that were being betrayed by
broke said now whatever you think of
Nigel parish he is not the Tommy
Robinson type figure I have a lot of
time for nitrifiers I take over from him
every evening on LBC and I've known it
for ten years so I think I know him
reasonably well I mean you just say a
lot of things I disagree with but he
does believe in democratic politics so I
think that's quite borrowing development
it's interesting where you say about
Tommy Robinson because we had a guest on
the show a couple of weeks ago who's a
youtuber who who was who's done
conferences with Tommy Robinson on
things like that and one of the things
he told us I don't think it was in the
interview but we went for dinner after
he was saying that one of the things
that you experience when you are with
Tommy Robinson is that there's a huge
number of people who will come up to him
they'll go take a look to the left take
a look to right make sure no one's
watching and then they'll come up to
Tommy Robinson and shake his hand and
say thank you very much for what you
doing there is a huge undercurrent that
I don't think anyone has quite explained
or understood of people feeling deep
resentment and frustration in this
country yeah where do you think that
comes from I think it comes from a
feeling that politicians have let people
down that's always been there to an
extent but because we have social media
now it's so much easier for people to
let people know what they're thinking
and 20 years ago if mrs. Miggins from 30
to occasional avenues gunthor wanted to
vent her spleen over something she she'd
write to the Scunthorpe courier now she
can start a blog she's got Twitter she's
got Facebook all sorts of different
mediums to make her views known now
that's a really good thing in many ways
for democracy it enables people to feel
that they're taking part in the
democratic system but it's also a great
danger because if they feel that they're
taking part but the politicians are
letting them down that that fuels our
feeling of resentment and in the end if
politicians continue to let people down
I mean who knows where that leads I mean
look at Italy as a good example I mean
okay maybe a Salim isn't the best he's
out because Italy has always had
political problems but I doubt whether
this current Italian government would be
there without the power of the internet
I mean the five star movement is
essentially creation of the Internet now
linked by a comedian by the way really
[Music]
thank you for all and you know it's not
well running its Italian there's
definitely
[Music]
but do you think part of what's happened
with Tommy Robinson part of what is
happening with brexit is the fact is
immigration is a major issue in this
country and mainstream politicians have
always felt enemies with tackling with
it and dealing with it and talking about
it open yes I think until about 2003
2005 that was probably the case we talk
an awful lot about immigration now I
mean people think it keeps saying it's a
subject the politicians try and sweep
under the carpet it's not at all
I mean I'm as white as a lettuce on
immigration I have no fear of
immigration I think that generally
people who come to this country come
here for a reason and that is because
they they see a country where they can
do well in if you are a Syrian asylum
seeker you come to this country
presumably because you think it can
offer you the sort of things that you're
that Syria cannot at the moment and
people say oh yeah but they should have
stopped in the first country in yeah
that's that's the system but they come
here part because a lot of them will be
able to speak English and we should
think it is a real take it's a real
compliment that they've chosen our
country rather than France Germany
Switzerland wherever and it's not
because they think we have a loose
benefit system I mean there will always
be the old person who comes here for
that reason I mean it's the human nature
but 99% of people come to this country
for the right reasons whether they are
asylum seekers or whether they're
economic migrants and in both cases
they're making rational choices which if
you or I had been in that situation we
would probably do exactly the same thing
and they're taking terrible risks to do
it so I look at it and again this is
something where I think my views have
become much more liberal since I've been
doing my radio show and from time to
time I'd say once every two or three
months I will devote an hour to asking
immigrants to this country to phone in
and explain why they've come here and on
what it's meant to them and with the
view of trying to persuade those people
who think that all immigrants are on the
take
to just happen pause for a second floor
and think what you've heard what these
people have said do you really still
believe that they're all evil people
come to bombers or whatever now that's
all I can do as a radio presenter but I
think that's almost a public service I
think every country has to have control
of its borders we clearly do not have
control of our borders as long as we're
within the EU I think it's a fantasy to
think that the number of immigrants is
going to be reduced to tens of thousands
after we leave because the economy will
always need new people if we're not if
we're not training people to do the
right jobs whereas the company is going
to get them from now in many ways it is
a scandal that so many of NHS nurses
come from abroad so many of the doctors
come from abroad because what we're
doing is we're stealing them from
countries that actually really need them
like the Philippines or Indonesia but
they're not going to stop after percocet
I mean perhaps it doesn't mean that
they're not going to come here anymore
Indonesia is well indeed but no Norah
people from Europe can start coming here
in the figures around this morning I
think showing that the net immigration
to this country has slowed from Europe
mr. Lowe since 2013 but we still have a
net inflow of people of 102 thousand now
I don't see that changing after
breakfast it at all yes the numbers
might come down marginally but we're not
going to get to this mythical
tens-of-thousands target and that's
where again people lose trust in
politicians whether they stick to a
target which they've never achieved and
which they know they can't achieve and
treasom a is the only one around the
cabinet table he still believes in that
target all over all of the rest of them
don't and then what Sajid Javid should
have done right from the start when he
became a secretary save the Prime
Minister were abolishing this target and
she would have had to agree to because
you're never stronger than on your first
week in a job and she couldn't have
afford it for him to resign straight
after amber rot and I think he has made
moves in that direction but maybe not go
as far as we could but let me forbid the
counterpoint to you on immigration
because I totally heal everything you've
said about and myself and immigrant but
on the other hand I sense that there's
there's a level of which immigration
becomes I don't mean unsustainable
necessarily economically but our ability
to integrate people and into us
Society while preserving social cohesion
within that society is limited I give
you an example right so I'm from Eastern
Europe I'm from Russia it's very common
in Russia or in other parts of Eastern
Europe Ukraine Poland all these places
for people to sit down and have a drink
in the park on the bench that's how they
do it right that's how we do it you
don't go to the pub you don't have pubs
necessarily in this country the culture
is different right now in the last 10-15
years in 15 years ago it would be
unheard of for people to be sitting and
drinking beer on a bench in a park in
this country it would be completely
unheard of unless they were homeless
usually right nowadays you walk around
whether it's central London or thumpers
wells where you and I live it's very
common to see lots of young men sitting
on a polar bench drinking beer but I'm
not saying there's anything necessarily
wrong with that
but that is just a visual reminder of
how quickly the country has changed now
there might be people who who are
troubled by that or concerned about that
or who feel that that's a reflection of
the fact that society's changed in a way
that they're not comfortable what's
wrong with that well I think generally
we have a really good record in this
country on integrating immigrants well I
mean what a lot of people are really
talking about are brown people that's
let's face it people don't know I know
they're not but which is why I gave that
example severally sometimes all that's
more it's more acceptable to have white
immigration than brown immigration
though for me that's no I'm not no I'm
not look at don't want you to address my
point which is not the racism but the
actual thing of people changing guys
don't try things that many people would
have a problem with the example you've
given there might be some I think what
people have a problem with is that
particularly the Blair government
allowed so many people in all at once
from Eastern Europe definitely and there
won't be there wasn't the infrastructure
there to support them
I think people accept immigration if it
means that they aren't going to some of
their children I'm going to suffer for
lack of school places or they think that
in A&E they have to wait longer or all
of those sorts of things and I think we
haven't got enough housing in this
country so people naturally say well if
we haven't haven't got enough houses we
can't let more people in I mean it's a
perfectly logical thing to think it
doesn't
they're racist necessarily right some of
them will be some of them won't be so
that's where again politicians have let
down people because they haven't
provided the infrastructure for the
numbers of people that have come in but
I think generally in terms of
integration in this country I think
we've done a pretty good job if you
compare particularly I mean you compare
us with France so you look at the
immigration that's happened in France
over the last 20 years and there are
genuine ghettos in in France where
literally French people indigenous
French people are scared to go now there
may be one or two areas in this country
that you could give that description to
but I couldn't name you more than two or
three there may be one or two northern
towns where for whatever reasons a
particular section of the population has
decided to settle there and it's almost
sort of there aren't any white families
in those areas anymore
now that is something that should -
might in my view should not have been
allowed to happen through the local
council or whatever they shouldn't have
allocated though those particular areas
when we're talking about effectively
immigration from Pakistan and Muslim
countries here but that is not
widespread in this country and I think
but we do also have to recognize that I
mean we're sitting here in West London
if we walk down the street I don't
notice someone's color when I walk down
the street if I hear somebody speaking a
foreign language on the tube does that
bother me of course it doesn't bother me
I'm trying to think what language is
that I find it interesting if you live
in a market town in the myth in the
middle of Devon where you probably don't
see a black person or a Chinese person
for months you it's it is something I
mean I remember once when I was walking
down the high street in Kraemer on the
North Norfolk coast and there's a black
man walking the other side of the street
and I was just sort of looking and
watching people and they were all
staring at him and that wasn't because
they were racist some of them maybe it
was because he was different and that's
what people find a challenge and that's
why people find different cultures quite
challenging when they don't understand
friend of mine few weeks ago for
everything we got Muslim family moved in
two doors down
where's Abby and what you know no you
tell me well you know who I mean it's I
was really quite shocked by this
conversation then it was two weeks later
Ramy up again and of course they're now
in each other's houses having cups of
coffee very friendly but he'd never met
a Muslim before now that's the challenge
for society how do you address that in
all of the areas where it is still a
novelty to see someone of a different
skin color and I know I take your point
about well nowadays it's not necessarily
skin color but that was all that always
used to be the case and for many people
I'm afraid still is and I think the
internet and I think television is
actually helped in this and that they
normalizes things and people don't feel
the threat maybe but they sometimes used
to from mass immigration and it's a bit
like a thing eventually people do when
they meet people who are gay they
realize that not all gay men want to
shag every gay man they mean maybe every
man is free yeah yeah so and it's the
same with image it's the same that I've
been just loaded set Muslim so not every
Muslim wants to bomb you they'll be the
very small proportion that and then but
they they will still say oh yes but the
others might sympathize with them well I
mean once you get to that level of
argument you can't really win it well
isn't that what imagine now says your
fellow LBC presenter isn't that exactly
what he says that there's a small group
of extremists and then a very large
group of people who do sympathise with
them
well I've I have never met a Muslim that
sympathizers with any form of terrorism
doesn't mean to say they don't exist
just cuz I've never met them but I think
I mean we all judge people by that I
suppose the the people that we meet in
our lives and I know I've had a couple
phone in on my radio show and whenever
there's a terror
Siddhant and I've covered quite a few of
the terror incidents because I could
break and within my show and I would
always encourage Muslim callers to phone
in to tell me what they think now
shouldn't they shouldn't have to do that
really but it's important for the rest
of the listeners to hear the
condemnation and from time to time
you'll get what I mean I can only think
of two incidents in eight years where
I've had somebody phone in to effect not
support necessarily but to show more
than a degree of sympathy and
understanding with what's happened and I
and I let them have it because I can if
it was on the BBC I couldn't but I can
and it's quite a powerful position to be
in when and again all you I mean I
remember one was a female
Zainab her name was and I kept her on
for about 20 minutes because I thought
it's really important that through she
understood I tried to explain to her why
I thought what she was saying was
completely wrong and it will range from
a huge it wasn't actually necessary
about terrorism it was on quite a few
social issues but it's quite that's
probably why I love the job because you
do have the opportunity at least to try
and make people think again even if
you're not going to necessarily change
their minds you've got to get into
question what they've been told by their
Paris I remember saying to what your
parent should be ashamed of you for
teaching you this which is quite
something to say to somebody and very
teacher like can I just say yeah I think
a lot of the fear of immigration it does
come from a fear of the unknown
and I'll explain it through children I
mean when I was teaching I was teaching
four-year-olds and I thought that this
experiment just for myself ready and
that I put a big bunch of crowns in and
they were doing colouring it and they
were coming in happy and then I got a
beak I'd grabbed a big load of the
Crown's and I moved them over to there
and I saw how they dealt with having a
smaller number of care crowns all of a
sudden that's when the argument started
to happen
and they started arguing and there was
pushing and there was shoving and all
the rest of it and then tears now don't
you think a lot of them physically a
child to be that's why I do it that's
why I did it for ten years but do you
not think a large part of the fear of
immigrants coming in is brought in by
austerity the fact that people see our
services get introduced the fact that we
see the NHS whether it's right where
it's wrong and starting to shrink and
die and being privatized and being taken
away the load of old bollocks I mean you
look at the money that is now spent on
the NHS it is infinitely bigger than it
used to be she's got another 20 billion
but apparently that's not enough you
don't solve the problems in the NHS just
by throwing money at it we should be
looking at the systemic failures of the
NHS but we can't because we are obsessed
by this fact that the NHS is loved by
everyone and therefore cannot be changed
we've got I mean Ann Widdecombe who
donkey's years ago shadow health
secretary she says it's like 2000 she
said at the time and nothing has changed
in the last 20 years she said we've got
a we're looking to have a 21st century
NHS using a 1940's bureaucratic system
and we don't have an NHS but you'll only
have an in a chair a National Health
Service when somebody in barrack upon
tweed will get the same level of
treatment on whatever as somebody in
central London and it's all a postcode
lottery um on so many different issues
now I I don't want to privatize enh and
then we don't release when I say this
but I don't want to privatize the NHS
but this pretends that it's being
subject to whole scale privatization
he's rubbish under Tony Blair I'm sorry
under John Major four percent of the NHS
was effectively privatized well it
wasn't even prior to us it used private
sector resources under Tony Blair that
went up to five percent and under David
Cameron it went up to six percent now
you could say well that's a 50% increase
on what it was under John Major came
from I mean if you want to be
propagandist that's a that's terrible
it's a 50% increase
94% of it isn't and I don't really see
that changing very much and this idea
that somehow in health care the private
sector is evil
most of us use private sector dentists
pharmacies are all in the private sector
GPS are effectively private-sector
contractors to the NHS most other
countries in Europe
I forget America because everyone so we
don't want to american-style house gases
and no we don't but if you look at
Europe that they aren't embarrassed that
they that the French or the German
system uses a lot of far more private
sector input than it does in this
country so the whole debate to me needs
to be reframed about well ok if we were
starting from scratch how would we do
this now and then let's once we've
decided that and let's have a proper
national debate on it once we've decided
that well let's see how we can get there
that doesn't mean to say we dismantle
everything that is in the existing NHS
but everything is so complicated now
there's no wonder we have thousands and
thousands of bureaucrats and
administrators in the NHS because the
systems are so bureaucratic that they
have to be there so I you say it's all
that all down to austerity well what see
what was the alternative to the
so-called austerity program that George
Osborne carried out we're still
borrowing 50 billion pounds a year I
mean if you believe that there's a magic
money tree that somehow magics up this
money that we can sort of get from
nowhere fine but we saw the result of
that in 1970s for 25% inflation and then
in the 80s the result of that was
massive unemployment the good old fun
days I'm kidding yes no but it's
interesting to me because on the one
hand you make a very good point about
austerity and I actually agree with the
dis idea that it was completely
unnecessary and ideological I think is
completely wrong on the one hand but on
the other hand we earlier talked about
your experience of talking to people
about things like the conundrum types so
how do you bring these two things
together this on the one hand the need
to reduce public spending they need to
borrow less
with the fact that when you reduce
public spending people know politics and
government is all about choices when
when you fight an election you have a
manifesto it's as well this is what
we're going to do and then when you get
into government you've got a certain
amount of money or you can borrow more
money obviously but you've got a certain
amount of money and you have to decide
how to allocate it and you have to be
responsible for those choices that
you've made and a conservative
government is inevitably going to make
different choices than a Labour
government now at the moment we have a
Labour opposition that thinks it can
spend spend spend they're making all
sorts of promises across all sorts of
different government departments well if
they do ever get into power and they try
and implement that those spending
pledges well the long-term effects of
that there'll be there'll be a
short-term feel-good factor particularly
in education and the NHS probably where
people say wasn't wonderful that we've
got all these extra resources but in the
long term because all politics is
cyclical the chickens will come home to
roost now I don't pretend I would
necessarily made the same choices as
David Cameron in Tereza may have made
but that's because it all individuals
will make different choices and and and
I would not have made some of the cuts
in some areas that that were made but
the amount of that the a just hasn't
been in financial terms the NHS has not
been cut local government services are
being cut Social Care is being cut quite
happy to accept that but you've picked
the wrong one on the NHS I'm afraid
[Music]
do you think we need do you think we
need to be more mature about how we
think and talk about politics I think
the like you make this point about
certain things they're gonna have to be
cut right I think so a few people
actually accept the fact that political
decisions will have negative
consequences a program I would say on
average in a three-hour program they
will have seven or eight lobby groups
pressure groups come on to explain why
the government should spend more money
on X Y or Z now I don't think that's
particularly responsible I mean though
there are reports that come out every
single day complaining about this that
or the other and yeah okay they said
well they've got to fill three hours of
news well is it really news that the
Royal Society for the Protection of
whatever demands there's another five
billion pounds of spent on something in
some cases it would be but the these
these desires for more money are
entirely natural but they're never
countered and you'll get John Humphreys
interviewing a Treasury Minister saying
there's now outrageous that you won't
spend the money that this particular
pressure group wants to spend but he
will never quiz the pressure group on
the fact that the money isn't there
it'll just be well why do you need to
spend this money yes that's a real
problem isn't it thank you very much and
goodbye
now as I say I don't think money extra
money is always the best way to solve in
its systemic problems within a
particular sector some some times it
will help reform but not always and yet
the the constant cries for more money
from the left are just based on the fact
that they want to soak the taxpayer they
think that none of us are paying enough
tax per ticularly the rich well what
what what classifies is rich in London
nowadays well according to the Labour
Party it's some of you earn seventy or
eighty thousand pounds
now if you're on twenty or thirty
thousand pounds you clearly do think
that somebody is on 70 or 80 thousand is
rich but try telling someone who's got a
fan
to pay mortgage in London that 70,000
pounds means that they should pay a
top-rated tax I think you'd have a bit
of a job to do that and in the end in
the 70s there was that this were called
incentives and so many people felt that
the tax system was working against them
and they were being unfairly treated
they just buggered off to other
countries because there was no incentive
for them to stay in Britain and I can
see a point soon where that's going to
happen here I think T the the current
government is in danger of that if they
bring more people into the 40p tax
bracket which they're threatening to do
to pay for this 20 billion for the NHS I
mean it's outrageous that somebody who's
on 41 thousand pounds a year is paying
an effective tax rate of 1 over 50% now
I would love to see a law that actually
ban any future government from taking
more than 50% of someone's income
because I think it's just criminal and
what why should somebody have to pay
more than 50% of money that they've
earned and it is generally earned income
now you can do it unearned income fine
you can make a case for that bit more
but you can't tax people till the pick
up it's great because we'll have
long-term effects on the future of the
economy I think one of the things that
people are very critical about when it
comes to taxation is these big companies
like Amazon or Starks who get away who
see me paying nothing
I totally agree and to be fair to George
Osborne he actually did do something
about that which I mean every Gordon
Brandon has to be said but George
Osborne did now you can argue has he
done enough probably not but they are
probably getting 14 billion pounds in
which they wouldn't have had before so
that's something but I totally agree
with you some of these big corporates
need to be addressed and the thing is
they've always got tax lawyers he will
always find another loophole what one
will be closed and then another one will
open up and somehow the Inland Revenue
you've got to try and do more to do that
they have they've employed a lot more
people to look into this and to try and
tackle it you're never going to
eliminate tax
evasion or tax avoidance you can
actually do something to mitigate it do
you don't think that's also an issue of
political will yes because a lot of
these people who are not paying the
taxes they're in cahoots with the
politicians their friends they go to the
same dinner book cocktail parties and
dinners and they meet on the same yachts
with Russian oligarchs I'm gonna phone
into your radio show experiences by
immigration yes I came to this country
to buy mansion in Chelsea so but do you
not think that's what a big part of why
Amazon and Google and all these
companies can avoid paying there was
always a lot of chatter about the fact
that David Cameron's former chief to
starve Rachel whetstone what she Michael
how was one of the other but there was
this little group of people around
Cameron that all went off to work for
Google or uber or wherever and I think
that was I mean that it certainly gave
the impression that people were in
cahoots do I believe that David Cameron
or George Osborne changed government
policy because they knew someone within
I'd like to think not I mean I do wonder
how he would get away with what they do
I'm it's probably because there's a
whole generation now in London of under
30 year olds who wouldn't ever think of
taking a black cab because they always
take you that and that's why in the end
when Sadiq Khan didn't renew their
license I always knew he would in the
end because there would be there would
been a big backlash against that I think
there are sometimes relationships
between politicians and people in
business and the media which are
unhealthy which leave the public to
think that there might be things being
done inappropriately even if there
aren't I mean I have this a little bit
when I'm interviewing politicians that I
know and I've worked out that if I
interview a politician who is a friend I
tend to give them a harder time because
I'm conscious that there'll be people
are various areas and given them a soft
time because he knows that David Davis
good example on the day after he
resigned
I didn't known to be with him
and I knew I was on a hiding to nothing
but the news of Boris Johnson's
resignation broke just as we were
halfway through this interview so that
would that gave a good news line out of
it but Jillian Reynolds the radio critic
of the Sunday Times she said that that
was a really good interview because I
knew him and I asked hard questions he
gave coded answers now she doesn't know
like to me particularly she described my
voices being whining on one occasion I
mean as if so that was I took I really
was very grateful that she wrote that
and then I was talking to David on the
phone a couple of nights ago and he he
said I did five interviews that day that
day I TV BBC the third one wasn't it and
then Julie hi Brewer and you and he said
and to be honest I thought your
interview with me was terrible and I
thought he meant I've been asking sort
of really bad questions and it was
genuinely a bad interview but a
journalist I know DM to me and said that
he'd run into David on Friday and he
said I can't believe I did all these
interviews and the two people that my
friends they gave me the hardest time I
thought were good because that guy I did
my job then and I do find it interesting
that I found that when I first started
doing this I did find it difficult to
interview people I knew that was one
time my food Rob how fun he's a lovely
guy MP for Harlow is a really good
campaigner and he was doing campaign on
something I come what it was now but he
clearly didn't know his staff and I
absolutely roasted him and then later
that evening my flame went off and I saw
his name appear of a oh [ __ ] here we go
any so I said hi he said done I just
want to thank you so what he said
because you taught me a lot in that
interview that I should not go into an
interview not fully briefed and you were
absolutely right to do what you did
not long afterwards saying to be a
pretty Patel and today Jeremy Corbyn was
elected leader of the Labour Party she'd
been put up by the Conservatives to
comment on it so you just said Priti
Patel your reaction to jeremy corbyn's
election well he's a danger to our
nation he's a danger to your families
economic security and off she went with
all his pre-prepared lines I and I just
let her finish and I said well aren't
you going to congratulate him it's not
my job to congratulate him and I should
be polite if you did and I've never
interviewed her since Rob Halford had a
really adult reaction to that she didn't
yeah make her I won't you will well our
time is running out so before we insult
you and never bring it in before we tell
you to say something that means you'll
you'll be like pretty patella because
again the question we always like to
finish on is what is the one thing you
think that no one is talking about that
we ought to be talking about god I could
say something try it like mental health
but we kind of are talking about mental
health now and that's certainly one
thing that when I was doing the evening
show on LBC I mean we've got a real
reputation for that and I mean making a
phone-in on depression interesting it is
sometimes a challenge but boy did we do
that we got shortlisted for an award
from mind for doing that but I think we
are talking about it now in 2018 in a
much more different way that we did in
2010 what's subject to I think we should
be talking about well I mean I go back
to the NHS I mean we are talking about
the NHS but we're not talking about in
only any meaningful long-term way and I
would love to see a proper national
debate about the future of the NHS
because we're not having it it's become
far too politicized which is inevitable
when we spend 1 in 6 pounds of taxpayers
money goes on the NHS as people say oh
well maybe you should just have a ban on
political board that runs the NHS and
not have any politicians involved with
it
well I'll actually want politicians to
bet they've got to be accountable for
the money that they're spending on my
behalf so you can't take politicians out
of running the NHS so I think that's
that is
a national debate that we should have
and possibly also on how West Ham can
win the Champions League yes I'm a West
Ham fan are you I'm indeed yes straight
up this could take about half an hour I
don't agree with Sean and we'll [ __ ] but
that's do you know I do
really yeah that's where it's probably
gonna do another show in DL thank you so
much for your on Twitter at at in Dale
you have a podcast how the podcast I do
with every week with Jackie Smith the
former Labour Home Secretary it's called
for the many and we talk about the
political events of the week but it's a
quite a fun podcast
and very very smart because she has got
off filthy mind it's wonderful day go
and there you're working on if you want
to talk about with a clitoris and we do
also write a book together cool well
editing a book called the Honorable
ladies it sounds quite dry but it's a
collection of biographies of every
female MP that's ever sat in the House
of Commons because at the end of this
year it's the hundredth anniversary of
Nancy Astor being the first woman to
take her seat so the first volume goes
up to 1996 there's a hundred and
sixty-eight different essays all written
by female politicians or academics the
second volume has got from which case in
1997 219 220 18 has got 323 in so you
can see that the difference in numbers
that there are now and they've got some
fascinating stories as a female Tory MP
from the 1950s called Patricia Ford who
turns out to be the step-grandmother of
Bear Grylls
what a great winter but actually finally
if any Russian oligarchs or any other
people want to phone in to your show and
give you some grief how do they do that
they do that between four and seven on
LBC it's very easy to do I do I actually
do know a Russian oligarch believe it or
not and it isn't you young to be an
oligarch I'm an oligarch son
yeah do you have one of those like
Superboy racing cars you drive around
Knightsbridge yes a Vauxhall Astra
so between four and seven on the OBC
perfect thank you so much for coming a
moment I may be changing but we've got
an exclusive here we do indeed and on
that note thank you very much for
watching if you've enjoyed it please
please please tell a friend give us a
review on iTunes
five stars please leave a nice comment
if you want to follow me I'm a failing
human I'm a constant in kissing and
remember to subscribe on our YouTube
channel and there's a little bail thing
next to subscribe thing that will make
sure that you get the videos you get
notified of the videos when they
actually come out thank you very much
thank you so much
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]